now tonight as you may or may not have
noticed the winter olympics are now
underway yep that's right the hostile
regime of the communist chinese in
beijing make no mistake this is an
international disgrace because of its
vile communist dictatorship china is a
uniquely well awful terrible place on
earth the vast majority of their 1.4
billion people they live in abject
poverty and squalor and by the way
they're the lucky ones china's ethnic
minority muslims
the uyghurs they're forced to live in
camps where they're used to slave labor
torture
murder happens and one of china's star
tennis players just disappeared after
accusing a communist official of rape
her claims were wiped right off of
china's internet there is no freedom in
china
no freedom of religion no freedom of
speech no freedom of thought no freedom
at all
you can be thrown in jail for using the
wrong words believing the wrong things
or sharing the wrong links online
censorship that rules the day and if i
were in china i'd be locked up probably
right about now for this monologue now
let's not forget china infected the
world with the kova 19 virus then they
covered it up and millions and millions
of people worldwide died as a result
we're going to have a lot more on china
the olympics coming up but let's be
clear
this is a shining real world example of
the left's ideology in practice
authoritarianism we call it if bernie
sanders had his way this is what the u.s
eventually would look like this is why
we are so adamantly opposed to
censorship
cancel culture boycotts all the things
we discuss often one of the reasons we
criticize fake news cnn is not just
because they frequently lie and they
spread conspiracy theories and they
advance one hoax after another but also
under jeff zucker recently fired cnn
wanted to end fox news he hired multiple
high-level staffers their only purpose
was to watch and to track and to stalk
people like me and others on fox news
and people on talk radio and get us
taken off the air or boycotted and
silenced and because as humpty dumpty
once hysterically squealed our opinions
are poison
this all happened while zucker and his
co-worker girlfriend coordinated with
then democratic governor cuomo i told
you there's a lot more to this story now
we're getting it anyway and presumably
other democrats they wanted to take down
trump they were trying to build up
andrew cuomo into a presidential
candidate and i'm sure we're going to be
learning even more about this unraveling
scandal in the weeks ahead but it is now
official fake news cnn they're imploding
zucker's gone the knives are out and
according to reports uh fake jake tapper
referred to chris cuomo as a terrorist
wow
jim acosta is openly worrying that cnn
will become fox news light caitlyn
collins apparently according to reports
had a fit of rage and get this the
discovery executive who's soon going to
take over fake news cnn had this to say
about the so-called facts first network
take a look
we have this great entertainment menu uh
which should keep people in in in the
home from the kids to the grandparents
why would they go anywhere else and then
we're the leader in news to the left
and we're now you know one of the
leaders
definitely did you say to the left man
you weren't kidding
um no that that wasn't a side effect i
probably shouldn't have said that i'm
sorry
they're not even the leader of news to
the left that would be msdnc uh now
saslof his name it would later issue a
clarification claim he was referring to
the left side of the portfolio not the
left side of the political spectrum adds
a little mystery to it one of the
smartest guys on tv
i don't think that that was said by
accident no more to come on that and by
the way why is msdnc
why have they not covered at all cnn's
implosion do they have some kind of
secret agreement because that would be
pretty weird for two networks who claim
to be journalistic institutions right
and here's another question what's going
on poor humpty dumpty he and his
assistant i don't know some guy named
oliver whose grand ambition in life is
to be humpty they can continue to heap
their praise on their former boss
writing a glowing tribute to zucker
sounds like they're putting all their
chips in the zucker basket maybe
anticipating they won't be there long
maybe humpty knows his days are numbered
maybe he's trying to hop on to the
zucker bandwagon and see where he lands
next humpy for humpty for once might be
actually right meanwhile another guy who
loves censorship mark zuckerberg is also
facing severe consequences after a
terrible earnings report and facebook's
record drop in the stock market wow
zuckerberg's net worth just plummeted by
31 billion dollars by the way his entire
company i think was 250 billion now keep
in mind facebook has been hemorrhaging
traffic traffic ever since zuckerberg
decided to meddle
in the 2020 presidential election
remember he was also responsible for
censoring a very true and damaging
report about joe and hunter biden in the
days leading up to
the election maybe zuckerberg could be
more worried about creating an usable
platform
less worried about the political
opinions of americans who are not from
silicon valley and don't share his
radical left-wing views remember it
wasn't that long ago that actual
liberals promoted transparency they
so-called hated censorship still they
existed inside the democratic party now
with canceled culture dark money rules
uh the day among the radical left in
fact one schumer aligned group
just raised a hundred million dollars
from unidentified
donors hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else